folks
it's joe derosa from the taste buds
podcast please come see me live i will
be performing in philadelphia
pennsylvania at the punchline comedy
club this coming march you can get
tickets to that on my website
joederosainfo.com also right after that
i'm going to south by southwest and
doing some food related shows down there
so come check me out there i'll also be
doing some regular stand-up stuff too so
if you live in austin come see me at
those shows in april i'm going back
not back no in april where am i wait i'm
going west in april boys i'm going to
the irvine improv uh right outside of la
and then i'm going down to san diego to
do some shows again tickets available
for these shows for all my shows coming
up may back in austin at the creek and
cave june fort collins at the comedy
fort all of the tickets are available at
joederosainfo.com
and if you're in new york come to joey
rose's bar and sandwich shop open six
days a week now tuesday through sunday
opening at 12 p.m every day come get a
sandwich and an affordable delicious
beverage
come see us joeyrosesnyc.com
what's up everybody let's talk tour
dates real quick this coming week i will
be in madison and chicago that's
february 26th and 27th uh at the
barrymore theater and the vic theater
those are on sale right now we have sold
out the first shows second show still
tickets available and i have just
announced all these dates they're
currently on sale right now these are
new dates april 15th in louisville april
16th in evansville april 23rd in tulsa
april 24th in oklahoma city june 10th in
rochester june 11th in syracuse june
17th in milwaukee june 18th in
minneapolis and june 24th in hampton
beach also of course the big show the
new york show the hometown show the only
one i've ever done here is the beacon
theater on may 14th every one of those
dates available right now at
savolcanocomedy.com thank you
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah
hey taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds today's battle is egg
rolls versus shrimp cocktail two titan
appetizers but also other things
like what
well these both turn up on hors d'oeuvre
platters
and at party spreads and things yeah you
know you can buy frozen egg rolls for
you know your your you know we we've
talked about hors d'oeuvres a bit last
week because of the super bowl but um
yeah nobody want a shrimp cocktail as a
maine right
no shrimp cocktail is available at
parties it's an appetizer it's uh an
accoutrement but it's not really a mix
it is it is yeah and it's but in the
same thing with egg rolls
but there's the times when you crave
both where you feel like you could do it
as a maine where you want it so bad
you're like you're like i'm gonna order
six egg rolls and that's gonna be my
dinner i have big opinions on both of
these yeah me too um but before we get
to wait a minute huh i've never done
that
don't worry i never thought to do it
thought to do what just order six egg
rolls and eat egg rolls as the main i've
i've danced around six might be above
the serving size even for lunch being
honest there's been times at lunch where
i've gotten three egg rolls and that's
my lunch i've never done that now i have
eaten two egg rolls with my entire other
chinese food or that i do it twitter but
i never said i'll do three or four egg
rolls and that will just be my main
because i didn't think that like first
of all i like a variety when i eat but
egg rolls i have so few and far between
and they're never not good even a bag a
real egg roll is good i don't know i've
never had a bad egg roll now i want to i
have but we'll get to it we'll get to it
okay we'll get to it you're team egg
roll by the way i said a lot of nice
about egg roll already that's correct
and i'm shrimp cocktail but i mean i've
been i think crocodile's been my man
i've had an illustrious past with shrimp
cocktail and i will expose it all today
all right it's
i mean these are great these are you
look forward these are the co these are
the appetizers when you sit down at the
steakhouse or the chinese restaurant you
can't wait you this is this kicks the
whole night the egg roll is literally
like the freaking yeah it's the kicker
it kicks the knife i won't even eat my
whole egg roll first i have to ration my
one end grill egg roll through the whole
chinese meal
i take a bite or two of the egg roll i
get myself psyched
i start dipping into everything equally
then like
halfway through i'll dip back into the
egg roll and then i'll have eaten like a
half of the egg roll at that point
and then another two thirds and then and
the last thing i'm finishing with is if
i'm in the restaurant
i will eat the whole egg roll first and
then
coffee style call for the garcon to
bring me another one
it is at your beck and call if you're in
the restaurant if you're ordering a
finite number to the home you have to
ration i well that's why i get two or
three to go into the meal i'd love to
know the nutrition facts on an egg roll
the reason i don't go in hard is they
just feel like a ball of oil right it's
a tube of oil gotta be terrible for it
it's gotta be bad they took
essentially lettuce it's cabbage and he
said let's wrap it in bread and fry it
you know what's wild cabbage outside of
an egg roll
right now i don't even like we're
outside of coleslaw yeah or outside of
coleslaw or beef and cabbage no no not
really though i mean you wouldn't i
wouldn't i don't love corn beef and
cabbage i wouldn't be doing cartwheels
just court for for the cabbage honestly
if coleslaw and egg rolls
didn't exist i think cabbage would go
extinct
uh nobody would want to be worthless
yeah if it weren't for corned beef and
egg rolls you're right am i am i crazy
but and buy in if you like but
egg rolls
corn beef and cabbage and coleslaw name
another thing with cabbage besides a
patch uh sometimes a stuffed you missed
that joke i thought oh patch kids oh
okay you just no okay but sometimes
sometimes stuffed peppers
people will make a cabbage and beef base
and put it in a stuffed pepper
that that is done at times but
we're not talking about a snake yeah but
i'm saying yeah but what uh do people oh
jesus lord you know i don't want to i
don't want to shut it off because i'm
expecting a call i got you we'll put it
in your crotch you feel it buzz yeah and
that way it doesn't dig it's not on buzz
it's just on silent
no if you turn the ringer off it's just
automatically on but it goes to silent
for me why would you do that i have to
go into the why do you do this
why do you make it all so difficult yeah
you put on vibrations
i will say something though if it
vibrates under my leg i'm gonna have to
look at it just the same as the ding but
the ding at least isn't is an audible
annoyance to the podcast okay well then
i'm doing it at least okay well then i'm
doing it for the listeners yeah there
you go all right so i'm going into how
do i do this now
this is nice all right let's just leave
the ding on for now leave the thing on
leave the ding on leave the ding on
leave the ding he told me you hurry up
he told me
[Music]
that's what he sounds like yeah the uh
but let's not short short the uh the
shrimp cocktail because the shrimp
cocktail i mean nothing excites me more
arguably than when i see the words jumbo
shrimp cocktail on a menu yeah and at
that steakhouse you got that pre-dinner
cocktail yeah and you see when the lady
brings out because it's better when it's
the lady
it's more fun when it's the late i don't
know if it's better when it's a lady but
it's certainly shrimp cocktail is better
when someone brings it with a bow tie i
i see i like a ladybug
cocktail it feels it feels nurturing to
me it feels motherly well a lady
bringing anything is good though or or
uh an old man bringing it to me
i would agree i think i actually would
like an old man in a vest and tie more
than anyone my shrimp cocktail is most
delicious
when an old whitehead man and italian
vest drops it off right i all right all
right i got you and i also it is one of
the few foods that i actually will get
mad
if you say can i have one
not you anybody well it's one of the few
foods like when somebody's like can i
have one of those i'm like i'm like you
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because it
is shrimp it is uh supposed to be like
for kings and queens right yeah wow
there's not a lot of them it's precious
you get what are you going to get fill
you up yeah maybe six if they're little
i'll tell you what i don't like when
someone calls it jumbo and you get it
and it's nothing but jumbo because i've
eaten a shrimp cocktail that is the size
of like
nearly like a half a banana i love it
those big ones that you gotta take three
bites out of it yeah but then sometimes
they say jumbo and these little flimsy
fire yeah
that sucks and it's like jumbo yeah if
you're in a diner and it says jumbo
shrimp cucumber there's something in
between [ __ ] and the big ones that's
is passable but sometimes they'll say
jumbo and they're like medium sized
shrimp
let me know let me not get into the let
me not get into all the all right the
cons against the shrimp right now all
right all right fair enough i'll just
say that i like it i'll tell you
what
maybe oysters but what
is
uh uh uh uh what's the sauce
cocktail sauce yeah horseradish what is
what goes better with that like i think
it's number one pairing is shrimp right
yeah cocktail cocktail it was british
is it all children shrimp it's great
it's great with um but it's a seafood
clam strips yeah yeah but i mean it's
but nothing it's better with nothing
it's really good with oysters too but
shrimp cocktail tops let me ask you a
question what are you dipping a shrimp
cocktail in if it's not all right you
know what
is it
stop stop it
who's dinging you you know it's
people in the group chat bro i can't
what group chat
do we hang into that now oh my god if i
said group trap i think it is you
silence it that was one of our group
chats okay but i am just one of them how
many group chats no i mean that was that
was not a group chat
that was one of the group chats that
texted right now but i got multiple
group chats so it's going to sound like
ding ding ding ding ding ding i have
grown to hate the group chat yeah i've
grown to hate the concept of it i can't
stand it no way you uh
i'm actually i think everything in life
just has a shelf life for you until you
say i've grown to hate the concept of it
and i can't stand it yeah what have you
not turned on in your opinion star wars
you've never grown to hate it what are
you nuts
indiana jones i'm a crystal skull fan
okay oh but those are just movies what
about like many bands uh that i love i
will stick with but
if i was gonna give you a pie graph of
things you grow to hate and eventually
can't stand and things that stay the
course with you what is the breakdown
the things i grow
on i get what you're going for and i
wish i had a funnier answer for you but
honestly the thing is going to be funny
babe i just needed to the things i grow
to hate are usually something new
that i'm introduced to that it seems
great at first and then it will get
overused like
lou begga is a good one
uh ricky martin yeah yeah yeah uh no but
like but like like uh like uh
what was that what was that app where
you made the short videos
vine like vine like when vine came out i
was like this is the greatest social
media i loved it i did it all the time
and then like after like two years i was
like i hate this i can't stand it it's
so obnoxious please lord please lord
what do you have an archive of your
vines how could i they're they're
they're gone i thought maybe you might
have had them on like your phone or
something no but why
because i want to see what you did in
the sixth sentence they were actually
very playful and like i love it i'm not
saying it's gonna be bad i'm saying i i
want to enjoy them okay yeah no but uh
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait scroll down the case
that was the first vine i ever did that
was the first fine i ever did my god
pimp
all right oh i mean look we're gonna get
to the battle
but think about how many vines you can
watch at six seconds of clip before we
even have to worry about it i don't see
an account i just found a single lone
vine okay that was the first vine i ever
did i don't remember what i was saying
but i was in a green room you literally
look like your emo you look like you're
in the movie like singles
you look like you look like logic the
rapper logic
throw up a split screen right now of
logic and joe
old old school me and logic
oh yeah never noticed that you do look
like when he has the shaved head and the
certain glasses you look almost
identical
for real
don't you have better things to do
no you don't i believe this is what's
wrong with you man
you're so [ __ ] up i believe this was
backstage at the wilbur theater burr was
on stage i was opening for him
oh my god oh this was me doing larry oh
wait okay did you just find seven more
vines yeah
this is me and pete holm's doing him
hold on this is me
i'm trying to make it big
wait i'm sorry i don't understand what's
going on
oh my god
every time we talk i can't hear what's
going on what do you say
i'm just trying to
the gag was that i was just talking and
then pete comes and starts going never
was a thug till i graduated to what
never
joe i love this fresh new content this
is me doing larry david
i gotta say you took my advice on the
little side got you to the level it's
larry david talking about the hush 100
yeah uh
and then uh wow man i haven't seen these
in forever there's there's another of uh
there's a pete holmes one where he's
like dancing that i remember anyway
let's go let's see all these shits
there's the one with pete on his
sunglasses i remember
balls balls dick dick was balls balls
dick
this was the writer's room his tv show
okay okay
[Music]
oh no this was my first post
[Music]
your first post was just the camera
running i don't think i knew what to do
yet by the way this is content he made
in march 2014.
yeah wow
only seven years ago babe
isn't that the year i met you that was
the year we met i believe and that was
uh that was this was that was the year
of my first tv writing up but pimp go
back for a second there was a thing is
that matt mccarthy matt mccarthy did you
still do a standup this is matt mccarthy
i believe doing vince vaughn love shaq
you see your little side at the wall god
damn it should be a big sign you want
people to know where the love
that was vince vaughn no it was vince
not vince vaughn sorry vince uh vince
mcmahon doing love [ __ ] oh now i got to
watch it again oh yes
you see your little side that well god
damn it should be a big sign you want
people to know where the love check is
that now it makes sense i was like why
was that vince vaughn what's that one oh
this is pacino doing love shaq you see a
little sign by the side of the road that
says 15 mile to the left
[Laughter]
we were doing i remember one day in the
restroom we kept playing love shaq and
we were all doing like takes on love
shack
so i did larry david matt did vince
mcmahon pete did uh al pacino
i never met pete he's fun he's a very
funny guy
is he is he doing stand-up still yeah i
don't know i don't know if he's on the
road a ton i think he's got a new tv
show coming out i believe
there you go
guys i'm here to sleep i am here for it
wait
go back to that page and hit back there
was a link
no no back no no back
back the back button
how does he know to the no no to the to
the search
yeah just keep going back to the there
was a link i want to see what it was
that had my name in it scroll down
keep going
no no keep going keep going
this joe derosa einstein from the kids
in the hall
september 23rd oh
this was oh that's right okay sorry are
we just doing a deep dive on derozan no
no but they weren't i remember doing
this they asked what my your favorite
sketch of all time was and i said it's
the einstein sketch from kids law but i
was just talking about that on a podcast
so i was like why is that i know you and
i were talking about it recently was it
was that excel yeah yeah okay yeah maybe
pretty sure that's what it was anyway
all right but anyway
it's that's no that's the old me yeah
you're talking to the new me because i
am on
how do we get on this
shrimp vine oh things i loved at first
the group text yeah yeah group text yeah
uh
frozen yogurt
um that why did you start to hate that
just one day i i got this tart taste
from it and i was like i don't like this
anymore so reverse for me right i hated
it because the tart taste and then one
day i was like this ain't so bad and now
i look forward to it really yeah yeah
yeah i mean i could eat it i'll tell you
some things i can't eat anymore well let
me think about this things that i just
ate so much that i was like i hate it
now salmon
salmon i still love raw
like with sushi well i could do it and i
could eat it once in a while like if i'm
just like i just want something healthy
i eat salmon and salad or something but
it's not it's never enjoyable yeah lucky
charms fell out of favor for me and then
i and then it came back
i mean i can't remember the last time i
made lucky charms
it's because it's like wood except when
marshmallows in it no no one agrees with
that
[Laughter]
nobody wants nobody wants the the brown
parts
nobody wants to taste
whatever they are yeah yeah no not
that's who not that's not true could you
imagine eating a bowl of just that's a
yin yang if you had a bowl of just the
tan those make the marshmallows more of
a treat
that's what i tried to do all
marshmallows and you take it and you're
just like you're literally going to die
that night
it's a bowl of [ __ ] it's like it's too
much
i'm my head's going nuts right now
let's take it back rolls and shrimp
let's take it back to the egg roll and
shrimp cocktail okay yeah
shrimp cocktail
i mean perfect
segue
shrimp cocktail is one of the things
that that happened to me with all right
let's just jump into the battle this is
because you're going to say we we're
giving up too much let's just battle
let's go that's what we're doing i'm
sorry we didn't do the chance yet didn't
do the chance oh how could we be
battling if we didn't i thought you were
just like all i want to talk about is
egg rolls and shrimp i said all i want
right now um
no matter what happens i love you no
matter what happens i love you no matter
what happens i love you all right
b-a-t-t-l-e
butts see my new merch
i love it yes ours is coming out i
showed you things today they're at the
printer i know i had to get my merch my
merch done because i was taking it on
tour it's not up online yet but this is
one of the things it's a kraken
attacking the staten island ferry and
it's just my little my name right now i
wouldn't wear this in public i can't
wear my own merch shirts in public but
it's almost like you don't see my name i
told him
put my name really really small so it
just looks like a really cool graphic
tee and then you incidentally i'm gonna
take some of your merch home with me
today
by the way speaking of merch and new
things
uh big announcement
for the
loyal band of salsa windfall followers
that came from this podcast oh my god uh
we
paul my paul's the other guy and so it's
me and my friend paul
uh we have an album
that has been on the shelf for five
years it's completed it's mastered and
everything we never released it because
we kind of didn't know what to do with
it and given the interest from certain
people on this podcast we were going to
release the album
there's a brand new salsa winfo album
coming out it's called artificial birth
and it will be released i don't know yet
when it'll be released i'm talking to my
buddy who who owns a small label they
might put it out or we might just what
dude it's so easy to put out it's so
easy
so easy to put out well i want i want i
wanted to isolate people
it'll be digital and vinyl but vinyl's
so backed out right backed up right now
are you gonna do a music video
i think we're gonna do a lot of things
like we're talking about doing some
shows and like wow and we're we're
working we're working guys let's talk
about athletic greens have we talked
about athletic greens we have yeah we
know i use it every day i know use it
until i started using it because i have
it now yeah yeah it's great it's just a
mix that i pour very simple i take a
scoop out of my little canister i have
in the fridge every day i put it in a 16
ounce glass of water mix it up and i
drink it and it's all the greens it's
got so much in it uh it's it's vitamins
75 high quality vitamins yes minerals
whole food source superfoods probiotics
and
adaptogens
help start your day right it promotes
good gut health uh it curbs my appetite
although i'm not i'm not sure that's
what they're saying they do
but it does it really does i enjoy it
it's only 50 calories and it tastes good
it doesn't taste like what most green
juice tastes like which is like earth
and what i also like about it aside from
the nutritional factor uh that you're
getting all this good stuff into your
body in the morning i like to coast i
try not to eat right in the morning i
try to keep my meals truncated to a you
know a window every day if they can and
this helps you make that coast well that
might be i think what they're doing for
me it replaced my multivitamin that's
what it did for me instead of having a
multivitamin i drink this and it's
actually it's it is
more efficient and and i get the
benefits of it faster some people do it
for energy it costs less than three
bucks a day uh it has over seven they
have over seven thousand five star
reviews uh the athletic green is a
climate neutral certified company uh for
every purchase they donate to
organizations helping to get nutritious
food to kids in need uh including no kid
hungry here in the united states it's
also by the way it's trusted by leading
health experts such as tim ferriss and
michael gervais athlete greens has
athletic excuse me athletic greens has
been uh recommended by professional
athletes that stuff to me
carries water you know with a product
like this i agree you know
these are healthy people
seriously they're not us that's the [ __ ]
yeah right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into the fluent cold season it's
just one scoop and a cup of water every
day that's it no need for a million
different pills and supplements to look
out for your health take it easy
athletic greens is to make it easy sorry
athletic greens is going to give you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five travel
packs with your first purchase all you
have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com taste buds again that
is
athleticgreens.com
buds to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
warby parker they're dealing with your
spectacles
[Music]
warby parker's
committed to providing exceptional
vision care online and in stores
offering eye glasses sunglasses eye
exams and contact lenses i like that
there are ones glasses start at 95 beans
including prescription lenses try warby
parker's free home try on program order
five pair of glasses to try
on at home for free for five days
there's no obligation to buy any of it
ships to you for free includes a prepaid
return shipping label and you can try
your stuff on the comfort of your own
home so to do that
i've done it i've actually done it yeah
go to warbyparker.com
tastebuds if you want to do that i've
done it too
uh you take a little quiz and you order
the kit they send it to you try
everything on you send it back and you
know look
what i liked about it was being able to
try the style and the fit in the comfort
when i'm in a glasses store yeah
whatever it's called an eye place yeah
and i shop
uh
i i feel like i'm i get tense like i'm
trying to well a couple things one is
that you like you really can't get a
sense in the store with the mirrors they
have and like you want to like
like you want to like try on all these
different things but at home you get
them you could sit with them you could
actually wear them for a little while
longer because sometimes i've had the
experience where i've purchased glasses
and then i wear them for an extended
amount of time and i'm like oh these
actually pinch my nose or they hurt so
you could keep them on a little longer
to make sure they fit right you could
try them on with different outfits you
could just you know keep them on for a
day and just feel them out more you know
what i mean yeah and it's not just
glasses they offer uh you know one a day
contact lenses disposables uh they're uh
warby parker's styles range from extra
narrow to extra wide to fit all shapes
of faces and everything which is nice
because some of these products are built
for one type of face um download the
warby parker app if you like where you
can try
the glasses on virtually allowing you to
to check this stuff out on your phone
and seeing realistic colors and textures
and sizes and that's on your iphone x
again
five pairs of glasses try them at home
for free
warbyparker.com tastebuds that's
warbyparker.com
tastebuds on new music for whatever the
next record would be but i i called paul
and i was like
you know man like this got brought up on
the podcast when i wasn't even there and
people are starting to like write to me
about it and i'm like we should just put
the record out finally like finally we
found some people that
care
so um
we should do like a
you know what i just you just because i
was like you should do do some songs
before a live pod and we'll have like
some games this guest is that i was
trying to immediately put together this
little show in my head and i was like we
should just do it at the grammars here
once in a while and i'm like we should
do a residency at the gramercy where
we'll do like a taste buds one month hey
babe the next taste buds one month
and we'll do a one night uh
one night residency at the gramercy and
we'll do the each podcast every other
month i told chris what do you think
about that i want to do that right now
let's go really i've been wanting to do
that forever i think we could do that
and i've talked to chris about it chris
wants to do it we thought that you would
be the x factor and why we might not be
able to because of some sort of
competitive competition clause with what
we didn't know we didn't know if like
you had other like headlining dates in
the work i might have to wait until may
14th because on may 14th your boy is
playing the beacon theater here in new
york city that's right tickets are on
sale right this second at
savilecanocomedy.com
i have never headlined new york show so
i cannot put up a competing show at the
grammar i wish i was in town i wish you
were too i mean it would be cool if
you're gonna join me but you can't and
that is what it is i i wasn't even
saying for that i just wish i was in
town so he didn't see it oh that's cool
man hang out yeah yeah the um but have
fun that's awesome come on it's the
first time i've had lining the hometown
it's awesome
we're we're hyped for a pimpy we'll be
there we're going to record it actually
and uh did you guys do the garden didn't
you did yeah
okay okay yeah um okay i was yeah i got
you you do that's amazing that's awesome
i know it's a dream come true so i'm
super psyched this may 14th it's on sale
right now um but yeah this gramercy
thing we've talked about it a lot and
pimp
chris and i actually talked about
where i said
i we were talking i said chris we should
do a thing because because of the babe
fest that you guys did right i was like
we should do a thing called presh fest
where we all go out
chris was like dude we could do it in
more like lesser known cities so we're
not going into markets travel is what's
tough
we wouldn't do it anytime soon but the
point is is like it would be a fun idea
but basically what i was pitching to
chris is this thing that you just said
which is we all do a thing together at
at a small theater one night and we have
a blast yeah we should
a thousand percent do it yeah we should
okay yeah if we do the grammar she shows
can you cater it
yeah i i can have
employees cater no yeah
i want you to serve sandwiches no here's
a great okay this is a great story pimp
this is great
yes the answer is yes okay uh this is a
great story in fact joey rose's
we sent a food truck michael che the
great michael che hired us we sent a
food truck to the set of hbo's show that
damn michael chase show yesterday 100
sandwiches uh went out to che and the
crew big ups to che for supporting thank
you man that was huge for us really
appreciate it
um that's cool you so you got a truck to
go deliver it we rented a truck and it
did you drove out we put us we put our
logo on it and we drove out did you did
you make the sandwiches as they ordered
or did you have them and then you just i
was not there right but uh but i mean
the guys we're making this year okay
that's awesome any and you end up buying
100 sandwiches we they they it was for
hundred people oh yeah so we i don't
know how many sandwiches they ultimately
did that's so cool i didn't know you
could do that otherwise i would do it
for my crew too
uh you can do it and we can do it
awesome i'll do it for the crew soon
then great i actually catered joey roses
at the super bowl party that pimp was at
that i had and we had a really really
nice spread and and uh the thing that
kicked off the entire all the food
because we ended up having like
you know wings and rice balls and this
and yeah but it was three platters of
joey roses huge hit i've eaten so much
joey i've eaten every sandwich you're
really enjoying it you're not just
saying huge hit for no reason no okay
dude i've eaten every single one of your
sandwiches now okay and i can't even
every time i i have a new one i'm like
ah my my favorites change they are so
good i actually still have like a couple
of slices downstairs in tin foil because
tin foil
aluminum or 10
a little i don't know you used to say
10. you should be 10 for 10-4-0 i think
it's called aluminum foil now i think
tin is aluminum though isn't it
thin leaf of tin
tin foil oh what have you pointed out i
haven't done since i even had some
slices today really yeah thanks buddy
appreciate it some new sandwiches coming
soon so i just thought i just wanted
three platters i didn't michael chad he
ordered a whole food truck thanks a lot
thanks a lot for us we loved we every as
much love went into your three platters
as that went into that food truck all
right um but no this is a funny story so
i was uh headlining um
uh banana go go
it's just bananas where's it go bananas
jersey bananas right
great
people nice staff fun club the show's
very fun thanks to the buds that came
out it was really fun but um
i was telling the story on stage it's a
true story i was talking to robert kelly
the day i was doing this first show and
he goes where are you at tonight and i
go bananas
and i go where are you and he goes uncle
vinnie's and i go
what are we doing dude
with our lives right
and he goes you think that's bad he goes
to stefano is headlining the beacon
tomorrow
because he goes i was there last night
to see eddie vetter i wanted to hide in
the rafters
until he got there and murder him
and i go you think that's bad
he's having an after party at the beacon
after a show and i'm catering
which was the truth that's great and i i
was just i opened the show every night
with that story and i was just like i'm
finished
that's so funny
yeah
bobby i invited bobby to the super bowl
party too actually couldn't make it he's
so funny they're both i love both those
guys
uh i would like to fight you now oh [ __ ]
yeah sorry
got away from us
all right
all right let me tell you the journey i
took with shrimp cocktail
all right because i'm going to call back
to something you said earlier though
okay insane
go ahead you first well i mean with
shrimp cocktail
i grew up not
you know when you're a little you don't
just pound shrimp then there's a day
where you're like oh i see this i see
what this is tasty and i see the benefit
in this
and you know and then you go through
good and bad shrimp like when you're
getting those expensive tight like those
big
you know jumbo jumbo ones that like
steamed
out of steamed steakhouses
that's good shrimp you know right but
what is the
most likely shrimp you're getting it's
not that well you got different breeds
of shrimp
first of all when it's not deveined i
will tell you this i remember the day
that i didn't realize that shrimp had to
be deveined i was somewhere with friends
and i was in a restaurant and they
brought us a shrimp salad
i had a salad shrimp on it and uh
my friend's like oh look at all that and
i'm like oh what is that and he's like
that's [ __ ]
like that [ __ ] in their intestinal track
that they didn't clean out and i said
that's what that is yeah and i didn't
know that prior to that and ever since
then
i took a left turn in albuquerque as far
as shrimp goes
but that's not fair that that's but
that's preparation if you pay attention
though more times than not even in a
nice place they miss it no and then i
just feel like i'm eating oh [ __ ] not
true at all i have very rare tell me
about my experience though encountered a
a veined shrimp
okay by the way what do we call it
veined it's a log of [ __ ] in the shrimp
why don't they call it de-shitting it
it's not a vein you have to do that with
any animal you consume you realize right
the precious pork chunks in your egg
roll you know that came from a pig that
had to be de-shitted before it was
chopped up and turned into pork rolls it
would be like if i was eating a whole
goddamn pig at one time and i was like
did you clean this [ __ ] out you're
eating a whole shrimp man yeah you're
not eating holy [ __ ] they're all
different
they're being shelled all kinds of stuff
what i'm saying like saying a fish oh
it's gross because the fish has to be
gutted of course it has to be gutted
before you can eat it yeah but a pig you
could slice off a peak a a chunk of it
and it's not a part that needs to be
de-shitted
when you're running you're eating the
whole thing
because the pig literally was living in
[ __ ] 24 hours a day it has well it's the
crux of your egg roll is the pork chunks
nobody wants a porkless egg roll i got
news for you yeah but i'm saying
vegetarian egg roll if that's the only
thing on the menu i'm walking into the
next chinese place i'm thinking of pig
little pork little things little chunks
in my egg roll i'm not thinking of [ __ ]
in its intestinal tract when you're
eating a shrimp when you're eating a
shrimp no matter what it's the whole
shrimp i mean you're taking the head off
but it's the whole meat it's the whole
the whole body right i mean no but the
head's gone the legs are gone the shell
is gone but you're eating the the lion
[ __ ] like this you're eating the whole
body well it's a tiny you're eating the
blind share of the pig as well
most
there's so many different cuts you ever
see a gutted pig hole
it's a whole goddamn pig they just took
the guts out that's it you never saw a
pig hanging in a window split
no matter what
i don't lift a pig to my mouth and look
and see the whole body went to a pig
roast where they're cutting it off the
body of the egg
yes and that's fine but i don't look at
a pig's
intestinal tract with my own eyes right
before i pop it into my mouth with a
shrimp eater because it's been removed
no i'm telling you you see the crease
where it used to be no babe that but i'm
telling you a lot more times than you'd
care to imagine if you look they don't
always catch it you're going to you're
going to bed
you're in a bad tree you know what
you're doing you're going up to those
city island shrimp joints
you're going up to those shanty shacks
on city island
what are you talking about do we go to
city island there's all these like big
gigantic like you know crazy seafood
places oh is it really i don't know yeah
and then but then if you talk to anybody
from city island you go that looks fun
to go it's tourist [ __ ] it's
but you know like but why do we call it
devayne
i don't know it's it's because they we
call it deveining because did you have a
pimp or was it was that it the the dark
line the back of the shrimp is their
digestive check removing it matter
because it looks like so read it so that
someone can understand what you're
saying
although we call it deveining the dark
line you see
on the back of shrimp is their digestive
tract removing it is a matter of
personal preference and taste
not hygiene it's not harmful for us to
eat go after yourself if the vein is
really pronounced dark or thick you may
want to devein the shrimp for a tidier
okay so pimp i went you know oh my god
wait a second well i want you to google
if what if there's species
in that thing it says it's a digestive
tract
well tell me if there's poop in it
period
why do they call it deveining because
they can't say we gotta rip the [ __ ] out
it's actually not a vein in the
circulatory circuit circulatory sense
it's the shrimp the dark color means
it's filled with grit
yeah grit so replace the gr with an sh
it's filled with [ __ ]
grit this is big shrimp trying to market
to us
it's poop
it's body waste aka poop they just sit
and they're calling it
we're really focusing on the worst i
mean this is like crazy right one of my
arguments that egg roll is better than
shrimp is that a lot of times if i lift
a shrimp to my mouth it's got visible
[ __ ] in let's go back let's go back to
le which is not true you're eating a bad
shanty shrimp shacks and i will stick to
that okay
but i will say this i want to go back to
something you wait pimp you want to jump
in i just wanted to say doesn't it feel
like when you eat shrimp you're eating a
water bug that's why i don't like now it
does pimp you just ruined it for me
forever i'll never have another shrimp
let's go you said you said you said
something so crazy rolls you said i've
never had a bad egg roll you are insane
dude i honestly think that egg roll is
something that is made very consistently
everywhere no
no no no and here's why you're wrong
it's made consistently in new york area
and new jersey and pet and philadelphia
area chinese restaurants you start to go
to chinese places that don't have the
the american chinese culture of food
that we have here you go to l.a and try
to get an egg roll it ain't happening
tuts it ain't happening
you're getting a tiny little thing
wrapped in paper that looks like a
spring roll yeah do you ever buy egg
rolls in the store no i hate we're in
the grocery store spring rolls and i
grow it drives me nuts but do you ever
buy egg rolls at the grocery that they
make there they they're terrible dude
they're disgusting you got to make an
egg roll the right way and i'll tell you
there's about four states in the union
this great union of ours that we're
doing correctly you're out of your mind
i'm not out of my right
you're off your egg roller i'm not going
to come on
all right
i just want to go back to yours because
it's been loaded with [ __ ] so
i used to like get to get to where
you're going what do you do with if you
don't have cocktail sauce what do you do
with your shrimp cocktail a little
squirt of lemon on it what do you do
if i don't have coffee i don't like
tartar sauce i'll tell you how much
i'm not i'm not eating it if i don't
have cocktail sauce okay boom
that's part of the dish cocktail that's
why it's called shrimp cocktail okay but
a chilled shrimp is not is not good
without the cocktail sauce that says a
lot doesn't it it doesn't say a lot i
like chilled shrimp you won't even eat
chilled shrimp without the cocktail
sauce i will eat chicken so what is it
that you like
hold on a second i would eat ch this is
ridiculous that's what i'm saying
because i made a good point do you eat
an egg roll without duck sauce it bites
it bites it the duck sauce is part of
the dish just like the cocktail sauce
okay so you will eat it
yes i said i'm not going to order shrimp
cocktail if they go we're out of
cocktails so i don't know i'm not going
to enjoy asking you
is if there was a bunch of chilled
shrimp out
and there was no cocktail sauce would
you would you not eat the shrimp no i'd
eat them you just said you wouldn't no
what i'm saying sal is if i go to a
restaurant and i say can i have a shrimp
cocktail and they go you know what we
ran out of cocktail sauce but i can
breathe i'll go now i'm gonna get
something else it's not going to be the
same experience if i'm at a party and
there's chilled shrimp readily available
i'll eat it without the cocktail sauce
yeah okay
yes i'm just trying to just decipher as
if it's a cocktail sauce that you love
i'm saying if i'm spending money on a
shrimp cocktail i want it the way i want
it that's what i'm saying okay cause i'm
nothing i love cocktail sauce it's great
but i don't love shrimp all the time
it's a 50 50 shot if i'm eating a shrimp
if i'm like i'm into this shrimp
or i'll never call the shrimp back you
know what i mean no like sometimes you
ever get a shrimp that's like like like
very loose and like floppy yeah like
it's just it's just
it looks almost old like you don't want
to eat it
what about
i never do this
what about when shrimp
is bad
and it smells fishy and it's like yeah
that's called rotten food cell these
arguments you don't make something
seafood is known you've got to be
careful with seafood yeah
an egg roll
an egg roll is fried you're taking that
thing out of the plastic wax wrap you're
shoving that thing down your throat like
you're like a hunter but but you're not
speaking to the quality of the dish when
you say if if it goes rotten it's gross
of course
how do i know if my shrimp is bad if the
bodies appear loose within the shell or
if there are black spots on the shell
it's likely that the flesh has started
to decompose inside also ensure that the
shells are firm and glossy if the shells
are broken and slippery or slimy the
shrimp is likely to be spoiled and
should be purchased so what if you make
clams your muscles and any of them are
open
i'm just speaking to the i'm speaking to
the
uh a tribute the attribute that comes
along with shrimp which is it's seafood
and you got to be careful because you
you run a risk of having babies get that
but but come on what are we talking
about here we're talking about the dish
itself when it's right yes that's what
we're talking about i'm just telling you
about my experience with shrimp and why
i've fallen in and out of uh grace with
it yeah i'm telling you okay then let's
talk best versus best okay let's talk
best versus best okay you go to a
chinese restaurant nine times out of ten
the best version of that egg roll is the
exact same thing across the board hold
on no no let me finish you go to a
steakhouse
and you get the best version of a shrimp
cocktail it is
league's
grand slam above what you would get at
uh at a standard you know a tgi at
friday's
place that's because there's so much bad
shrimp you can't just have bad shrimp
there's classes or shrimp
right and i and i don't i'm not gonna
talk the best class
i i realize you know that doesn't make
any sense though because i have to talk
about the experience of eating shrimp
and i'm saying though i'm talking about
i am i'm talking about the whole thing
but i wanted to go based on best i said
let's talk best on best for a moment but
you have no scale of quality in your
thing it's either good or it sucks
that's it with an egg roll i i honestly
i rarely rarely rarely have an egg roll
that is not exactly what i needed to be
getting one off of often i often maybe
like
60 40 70 30 have shrimp that i am not
happy with does that make sense no
why does that not make sense because
i've i have not had that experience i i
every time i get shrimp cocktail i'm
pretty satisfied with it
you know or gloriously satisfied when
it's bad it's been you don't order it
enough you don't know because i was a
fan at the time i was a fan of shrimp
cocktail and the reason that i'm i've
fallen out of love with it is because i
ordered it so much that i i i've
experienced so much hit or miss that i'm
like done with it i'm done with it and
you know what if the [ __ ] comes
delivered to me with the [ __ ] i'm not
even sending it back i'm just like i'm
not eating this
well where are you getting yourself and
if it gets your tail from if it gets
flopped you can go to a question it's
not nice and chilled and it gets like a
little you go to a quality place with a
raw bar and that knows what they're like
it's yeah i'm not just gonna talk what
i'm saying is
an egg roll is way more consistent than
shrimp cocktail and for the most part
when i get an egg
it's a delicious
crunchy thing that i wanted in the
tri-state area and i
go to canada and tell me how the egg
rolls are up there go up to canada go to
canada i'll tell you why i live here
i'll get it i'll get a shrimp cocktail
in canada i'll be pretty goddamn i'm
happy why are we talking about flying to
another country i'm saying
the egg roll that you're defending right
now which i love which i'm a fan of is
an egg roll that is is that is
indigenous to a four-state region of the
united states
and when you go elsewhere
egg rolls take on a whole new meaning
and drop in quality like you can't
believe okay you're talking about
chinese food it's like it's like the
pizza argument where it's like it's like
or the cheesesteak argument whatever
there's this there's a region in the
country where that stuff seems to shine
a bit well well then but i guess i'm
defending that version and i guess i'm
screwed because if you're telling me
that it's not good outside of four
unions of this great country of ours not
four unions four states
yes then
then i'm going to get killed because
true shrimp cocktail is a global food
better help better help i like better
help we are sponsored by better help
they're great
uh this [ __ ] all right start again
better help better help i like better
help this podcast is sponsored by better
help online therapy
relationships take work folks and a lot
of us will drop anything to go help
someone we care about we'll go out of
our way to
help other people to treat other people
well but how often do we give that
treatment to ourselves i've only learned
recently uh for sure that self-care and
cell treatment is very important and
therapy is important that's one of the
ways i take care of myself i agree i
agree i think uh you know a lot of
people do it by hitting the gym uh they
make time for their haircut uh they try
therapy uh and but
at the end of the day no matter what
you're doing you are your greatest
aspect so invest the time in yourself
the effort into yourself like you do for
other people okay like that's important
mental gym people go to the gym all the
time they exercise you got to do the
same thing for your brain it's the
reason i go to therapy on a regular
basis you just get stuff out you process
stuff and it's just good health it's
just good mental health i talked about
therapy on this episode i talked we
talked about it on this episode yeah we
believe in it do it for yourself the
podcast is sponsored by betterhelp and
tastebud listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
buds that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash taste buds give a try and see why
over two million people have used better
help online therapy uh we're talking
about factor right now factor is uh uh
in-home meals get sent to you at home
right yes and you could choose from like
keto friendly carb light uh healthy
normal all this stuff they have all
these different packaging options for
the type that you get delivered right i
did it uh and i'm not kidding you
for for four days straight i ate factor
they sent it to me and
i was
eating healthier immediately because the
meals are only about 500 calories and
they're loaded with protein they're not
high in sugar or anything like that and
they sent these strawberry banana
smoothies
um
in a bottle that i would drink and
they're so low on sugar one thing is
like whenever you drink a smoothie or
something it's usually high in sugar
they were low in sugar i started my
morning off every morning by the time i
went through all the food and the stuff
i was like i was looking forward to it
so much i'm gonna order it again i'm
waiting for my factor order to arrive
yeah but i am very excited about it yeah
it's great and they have like really
really good meals too like and another
thing is i've done ones in the past it's
been a while now but i've done ones in
the past the factor sends enough food
that i actually am like i'm actually
getting full before i finish it which is
that's crazy so it's not about cooking
at home it's not about having to meal
prep for yourself
they just you pick it out they prepare
it for you and they send it and it's
ready to eat it's fresh never frozen uh
you can eat clean 24 7. after four days
i felt good about myself great i really
did um prepared meals are so easy but
they're good for you uh saves your time
they deliver chef crafted meals to your
doorstep eliminating the hassle of
shopping clean up because you can eat it
right out of the packaging they send it
in 29 meal options every week uh also
they learn your preferences which is
nice so yeah they offer vegan
veggies keto locale cold pressed
energy smooth plant-based protein
size it's really cool it's just i like
the way they package it too and uh yeah
i mean and you heat it you heat it up
for two minutes which is also like
lights out fast like
every meal i had was two minutes in the
microwave i love it so i would come home
be starving i had to get home from work
at like eight nine o'clock at night and
i just look and i end up eating a
healthy option instead of a terrible one
and it was ready in two minutes i love
it i love it i can't say enough about
the strawberry smoothie in the morning
head to go go.factor75.com
tastebuds120 they and we never said that
that part was going to be easy yeah and
use code tastebuds120 to get 120 off
that's code
tastebuds120 at go
dot factor 75 dot com slash taste buds
one two zero for a hundred twenty
dollars off
well
i wasn't gonna bring that out
i wasn't gonna bring that up i wasn't
going to bring that up because i do feel
bad for you
because it is a global food i don't
think shrimp cocktails much without
cocktail sauce go to chinese you ever
been to china i've been to china as for
an egg roll in china they'll scoff at
you
well it's american chinese food yeah
yeah i understand that but that's you
know there yeah oh i mean it's you know
i like a warm crispy flaky
pastry wrapped around some delicious
pork cabbage filling you crunch into it
it's crunchy and hot and then it's it
the texture is great on the chew i
always whenever i finish an egg roll i'm
always like i wish they were bigger as a
matter of fact this is my
my plea
my my my my
anyone that is involved in chinese
restaurants in this area
why not make a super-sized egg roll
make it twice too much no make it twice
as long i always want more when i'm done
with it but that's where you get two and
i will tell you this and i will promise
you this you will enjoy eating two of
those than a super-sized egg roll you
might be right
you don't want it it's amazing
it's like saying i want a super-sized
dorito you don't
you don't you don't it's they're better
in you know what i mean but like here
i'll give you another thing i'll give
you another accolade towards the shrimp
cocktail and a strike against the egg
roll shrimp cocktail puts down on the
table i can eat it right away
egg roll you're a bit of a bite in egg
roll it's too hot it'll burn the skin
off the roof of your mouth often with
egg rolls i had to learn from a friend
of mine having to learn not to be a
[ __ ] no but i like that the food comes
i'm hungry i can eat it right away a lot
of times with egg rolls i have to poke
holes in it with a fork and then press
down to get the steam out i don't know
the anticipation is even better then oh
please so the anticipation is i'm
driving to the restaurant and sitting
down and ordering that's the nobody
nobody has ever dropped an egg roll on
the table
in my lifetime where i didn't want to
immediately eat the egg roll and i don't
mean like eat it right away immediately
i don't mean eat it right away
i've had shrimp in front of me at
restaurants parties on the table where
i've opted to forgo the shrimp okay and
i've been at weddings where they've
passed around trays of egg rolls that i
didn't want because it looked like [ __ ]
and it looked gross at weddings yeah
you've never seen the little egg rolls
being carried around weddings and
cocktail parties but you're bringing in
you're bringing in or you go to like one
of these websites
you go to one of these dumb industry
parties for for comedy or whatever i'm
always taking the egg roll man and
carrying around the egg rolls egg roll
and that's not followed by me extending
my hand and clasping an egg roll and
then shoving it in time let's go to the
i want to i want to go to the phones
here no
yes why are we going to the phones i'm
not done talking all right keep talking
go ahead you keep talking will you
acknowledge my point though
what if someone like if we were at a
chinese restaurant and like i ordered a
combo and they bring out the egg roll oh
wait a minute wait a minute
the other most famous egg roll staple is
shredded pickerel
it's pork or shrimp egg roll that's okay
i'm talking about shrimp cocktail so you
can't have your thing without shrimp so
you can not argue guess what they're
tiny shrimp are you checking to make
sure they're de-veined when you eat that
shrimp egg roll i don't eat shrimp roll
number one so never never never do never
never do it nope never do it no i don't
need the small shrimp to that [ __ ]
they're full of a chemical [ __ ] i
don't eat baby little little little
shrimp shrimp i do not eat them all
right they're not good they have uh some
type of uh
here i have it here
why is shrimp so nasty that's that's an
article folks why is shrimp so nasty
important farm shrimp comes with a whole
bevy of contaminants antibiotics
residues from chemicals used to clean
pens
filth like mouse hair rat hair and
pieces of insects this is why they say
you should be farmed fish
this is all farmed fish
this is not you know
okay let's look up let's look up with
the what's in the ins the ingredients of
the tgi friday frozen egg roll you're
going to get a slew of chemicals in that
too we're not talking about that we're
talking about when it's done right now
i'm not talking about frozen food
that's your egg rolls your egg rolls
your frozen shrimp
is [ __ ] too but my point is
of course if you go to the worst version
of a year ago pimp i want you to look up
what goes inside the average
mass-produced egg roll let's see that's
a that's a that's a succinct article to
pull up oh what goes inside the average
mass producing the southwest egg roll is
there anything worse than a southwest
egg roll god it's great but if you want
to go into frozen shrimp right now how
disgusting is that no i just frozen
cooked shrimp i said the thousand raw i
said the south i get frozen shrimp all
the time you're eating a fish that got
killed eight months earlier
i don't care but we're talking gross
i don't think that's gross you're eating
a shit-filled fish i'd buy frozen kill
ramp that was killed time to supermarket
threesome
ice cold water and then i have an
ice-cold shrimp cocktail with it i do
that and it's none of your business that
i do that you ever eaten the shrimp and
get a get a smell of that that fishy
shrimp smell cause you're eating a
rotten shrimp salad no not just rotten
what are you talking about
what is some of the grow gross things
inside egg rolls there's got to be some
what about when you bite into a shrimp
and it's stringy oh
that means it's not a good shrimp salad
all right well then there's a lot what
about when you bite into an egg roll and
you realize it's from tgi fridays
what about when you're biting into an
egg roll you realize you're a chili's
and it's a south west
no i'm talking about the genetic
composition of an actual whole
shrimp like of a fish itself
the texture of a fish's shrimp's flesh
bro i'm not talking about the bran
not selling the egg anymore when you're
eating it like that that's not true
sometimes you can bite into a shrimp
just fine and you pull it and it kind of
like rips apart stringy i don't have
that problem i don't know what you're
not
you're not admitting to any of shrimp
cocktails i am admitting to false but i
am countering your argument about the
faults with the fact that that is not
quality shrimp i don't know what to tell
you there is a certain there's nothing
what i'm saying is
you i had to judge shrimp cocktail on my
lifetime of experience with this all
right
all right i'm just saying like it is a
valid thing for me to say one of the
reasons that i don't love shrimp as much
as i kind of used to is because i've had
so many so much experience with it and a
lot of times to me it doesn't it doesn't
hit the mark i want to see what some of
the fans are saying
don't you feel that way with egg rolls i
just feel like in egg rolls and egg
rolls and egg roll some are better than
others but leaving the worst egg roll is
like damn that's still a good egg roll
and i always look forward to an egg roll
no because i don't have it as much like
that shrimp is available believe it or
not no yeah because i'm not eating an
egg roll unless i'm ordering chinese
food shrimp cocktail is available way in
way more
pigeons found in the basement of chinese
buffet
in fargo this is what i mean get out of
the tri-state area
this is what you start fighting against
pigeons
found in basement oh no they're not
my dad my dad said that you should go on
in queens they're not serving pigeons
i don't know i don't know who knows
well let's what do they apologize for
just having pigeons i mean that's enough
to apologize for god
they're in a cage
but why do they have them
uh look they got 87 pigeons in a cage
i'm assuming it's not their pets i mean
it's not 87 is the whole thing redacted
i don't know what's going on
it looks like a nice restaurant too
when they're showing the the the dining
area that look like a nice restaurant
taken by the public health official
oh my god
they didn't like scramble to remove the
cages of pigeon when the health
officials showed up wow that's that's a
that's a set of stones right who are
they joey roses oh come on how dare you
look that looks like a nice little like
chinese restaurant right like if i went
in there it'd be good
yeah
you never know take us to the phones
all right john decker says shrimp
cocktail is a limp handshake and egg
rolls are a warm hug
sure
shrimp cocktail feels lazy class it up
with a nice glass and ice
yeah that's
maybe some jazzed up ketchup police i
love that he's saying it's it's not this
guy's talking defending a fried piece of
dough with pork inside no he says that
rightfully so he says that crispy and
succulent
is there pork i also like veggies yeah
veggie egg rolls blow
no they're great is there a fun dip
there better be otherwise it sucks also
babe duck sauce
you wanna if you want a touch from
cocktail which i do love i really do
love i love the cocktail sauce more than
the shrimp
okay but
duck sauce
what a treat no i love duck sauce
duck sauce to the egg rolls the
cocktails most of the shrimp that's what
i'm saying i'm not saying shrimp
cocktail is way better but i don't
remember brad pitt eating egg rolls in
ocean's 11. shrimp cocktail is the
cooler hors d'oeuvre and it's not close
okay also judging on cool
once i ate a whole platter of shrimp and
i threw it all up so i picked egg rolls
either way i hope deroza is yelling at
something love it when my man gets
heated
uh
egg rolls are more versatile shrimp
cocktail is just iced up fish with a
sauce that can't make up its own mind
you might win this one
nah after getting
you know
but this is that's not an argument i got
food poisoning from shrimp so now i'm
voting egg well it's not an argument
listen to this it just comes with an egg
roll they're giving it away i don't want
it okay that's terrible
because the reason you get a combo it
doesn't it's not free you're paying for
it you just pay for the combo
you don't feel like how is it even
argument egg rolls all day not even
close you don't feel like a fat [ __ ]
after eating shrimp cocktail depends how
many you eat but true
if you're doing what if you're doing
what your boy roses here is doing and
ordering six for the meal
uh troop cocktail was joe's name and
nickname in high school i don't get that
uh i feel the answer to your question
lies in another question is cocktail
sauce used for anything besides that
yeah because shrimp is the only good
part of shrimp cocktail oh he's knocking
cocktails oh really shrimp cocktail is
more i feel the exact opposite
uh
much like the roses shrimp they're
easier to pop
all right i like that
just ask yourself what would you rather
take in prison
i think the answer is
that's funny
guys it's shrimp cocktail these jokes
right themselves egg rolls are a flavor
delight i don't care how much they
remind me of the male anatomy
shrimp cocktail is what trashy people
eat to try and be fancy
i don't want oh scroll back up him
i don't want to eat shrimp [ __ ] i've
never seen one cleaned properly hand me
some fried goodness
that is an outrageous statement i've
never seen one clean way more variety
and ingredients in an egg roll shrimp
cocktail is a one-trick pony which i was
trying to say the shrimp is just the
entity of the coal shrimp the actual
body of the animal it's a hundred
percent
one thing i understand so when i'm so
when i'm eating it
you're like it could be good it can be
bad but
it can be both
because it's coming right from the sea
it's not like it's manufactured or
processed
uh shrimpies all the way uh
nope neither sorry uh an egg roll is
done right it's like a warm hug wow
that's almost wow somebody else said
that shrimp cocktail is so gross
yeah let's put some dead things in a
bowl of blood oh shut up come on guys
see i don't agree with this shrimp
cocktail because egg rolls vary in taste
too often i find them pretty consistent
nothing worse than the surprise butt of
an egg roll that tastes like hot garbage
i agree derek that's what i was saying
that's what i was saying
scroll up him shrimp cocktail needs
sauce to survive i agree egg rolls will
live on with or without
viva growth i i have driven back and i
need to make this point to you egg roll
fans i have drifted now you're gonna get
heated let's go i've been gone baby
let's go before the bell let's slug it i
have driven back to the chinese
restaurant 25 minutes in each direction
because they forgot the duck sauce you
have to have the sauce for the egg roll
and eggroll without the dipping sauce is
terrible
why are you getting heated about that
because this concept
anybody is eating
first of all first of all if you drove
50 minutes round trip to get duck sauce
we where where were you staying that the
closest my mom and dad's house was 25 my
mom and dad's house the the chinese
place was 25 minutes away that we like
to order there wasn't a supermarket near
my dad went and got
they don't have real ducks you you
[ __ ] amateur
have you ever bought the duck sauce at
the supermarket
no you got it you don't have to get the
same thing it comes out of those glues
it's not the other thing it's not i've
bought it i've bought it many times it's
not the same thing it's like just like
the difference between blue cheese
dressing at the restaurant and blue
cheese dressing at the steakhouse it's
not even the same [ __ ] ballpark if
they're making fresh blue cheese
dressing yes i'm telling you you're
buying manufacturing
chinese food for us he came back
i said where are the sauces
he said i didn't check i guess they
forgot them you want to talk about a
meltdown
i just didn't even understand i was like
how did you not check for the sauce i
don't understand what are you doing i'll
be honest you went back to get duck
sauce to slather over everything no it
wasn't just because you know you
wouldn't have eaten the egg roll without
the duck sauce you waited one hour
i went back and i got the egg roll and
the hot mustard the the egg roll is not
happening without it that's it the hot
mustard or the duck sauce the duck sauce
i can get by with just duck sauce but if
i'm getting if i can get duck sauce and
hot mustard i'm getting it oh because
now look how fun the egg is put it on
duck sauce hot mustard a mixture of both
isn't it great the only thing greater
than an egg roll is derosa's hair that's
a nice point it says greasier gree
all right give that guy the win
give that guy the win yeah all right uh
follow
at m-e-l-g-a-r
all right let's go why don't we say
follow do you think people are following
these people oh we're just gonna be nice
it's a nice thing to do
is that okay yeah i'll just i'll just
i'll just i'll just dismount with this
i'm always
and i really mean this i'm always
excited oh my god how many times are you
gonna make this point
i know you've said it you said it three
times we get it i'm i'm i'm i couldn't
even tell you what percentage i'm
excited i know you you've made this
point you've made this point great
dismount i'm going to dismount with this
are you always excited with this i'm
going to discuss always excited
with it you dismounted now it's my turn
i'm asking you the question before
you're repeating yourself wait one
second yes yes i love you guys
yes
yes i loved crim cocktail crimp i love
shrimp cocktail everything for the fancy
appetizers it is king every time you see
shrimp cocktail you're excited you're
like oh my god i can't wait to oh you're
like you've got to be in the mood for
shrimp cocktails no i love shrimp every
time since i was a little tyke i don't
believe that also
are you and you're not always excited to
eat negro
i love egg rolls but i'm team shrimp
cocktail right now
okay
[Music]
all right
what do we got i think you're going to
win i don't think so because 75 just
told me egg rolls are only good in five
states well there was a lot of pro egg
roll stuff on here pimp give it to us
oh jesus christ my god going into this
dude i really thought i was losing i
swear to god i did not think pimp humble
pie
i did not think that that that i would
like to point out
not even not only did i think i was the
only fans i didn't think i was winning i
thought it was a big underdog i would
like to point to the fans that my
original pitch for this battle was egg
rolls versus chicken fingers no they
weren't and yes it was oh correct and
you told me egg rolls are going to get
slaughtered nobody likes egg worms oh
they won't be chicken
you got to do it against shrimp cocktail
once again this man has sabotaged me in
a battle now i stand by everything i
said but you think he doesn't know what
he's doing
you're a louse
you have to look in the mirror and blame
yourself if if i if i if i positioned
you with that and you accepted it the
blame is on you i wasn't doing it
because i thought i thought
as a matter of fact i said it during the
battle i thought shrimp cocktail was put
on a good and i thought egg roll was
really put on a good front i thought i
was going to lose i thought it was put
on a good front not well look i didn't
think i was going to kill you which is
what i did
68.4 percent egg roll to 31.6
shrimp cocktail i did not think i was
going to have more than double your
percentage i know in no way shape or
form but by the way but if you looked at
me and you said i'll do that
and you said i'll take shrimp cocktails
i know i'm just starting to learn your
ways yeah all right
[Laughter]
just say the words please
just say the words please
i still love you babe
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the